hey everybody its Jesse and I hope
everyone had a nice weekend I had a
little bit of a long weekend had Monday
off so far there's no stream yesterday
let's see today I'm gonna try something
a little bit different so as you know if
you've ever watched this before I only
show my screen and so no one ever gets
to see my face so I thought today I
would have two streams so the first
stream is just going to be the normal
stream that that you all are used to and
then the second stream is going to be
the opposite view so you'll get to see
my face as I'm doing this stream in that
stream is going to be on Instagram so I
could have done it like a little box on
the side of the screen but for a couple
reasons I decided enough to do that the
most important reason being I don't
really know how to do that and I didn't
have time to look it up so right now I'm
still rushing to finish as much as I can
on this project by I think tomorrow is
the last day that I can work on it so I
spent a long time over the weekend I
think Friday
I stayed up pretty late on Friday
working on this and did some work on it
on Saturday so if you check out the live
version of this site at catechetical
Scone it's going to be a little bit
different it won't look that different
to you all since you've been seeing the
development version of it but it's been
a while since the the production version
you know at the actual URL has been
updated so so that's all updated and oh
I'll fill you in on some of the changes
that might
then that were different that weren't
even on the dev server I did make a few
changes like that
hey I just checked a lot hey everyone Oh
Andrew sorry you can't you can't be with
us in the live chat totally understand
about work so andrew has to work so
can't be in the in the live chat but
hopefully you can you can catch the the
live streams later in the week so okay
all right the analytics were a little
bit weird it was showing that I only
have three viewers for a few minutes now
I'm up to my normal right around 50 is
pretty normal especially for the
beginning occasionally I'll get more
than that not sure why it probably just
depends on who retweets the the tweet
saying that I'm gonna I'm gonna stream
and how many people that goes out to but
anyway oh I I was mentioning I'm gonna
have the second stream showing my face
as I'm coding on Instagram and my
Instagram account is its public so
anybody can look at it it's just Jesse
dot whyville so Jes se period WEEI GTL
and I'll type that in the live chat if
anybody's interested so I don't really
know if anybody is interested but it'll
give me a good idea I guess if I should
look up and try to figure out how to put
my face in a little box on the corner of
the screen if nobody really cares then I
won't worry about doing it but I had
never done the live stream on Instagram
before though so I thought this would be
a cool way to try that out at the same
time that I'm doing this so so anyway I
just typed my Instagram name in the live
chat there in case anyone's interested
and I'm not even sure I'm not exactly
sure how the UI and everything works for
for Instagram live anyway so alright
looks like some you saying don't worry
about that don't need to see to see the
face better to code that's what I always
thought that's why I never bothered with
it
but then I see like a lot of other
people who stream even streaming code
also they have their face in there so I
didn't know if that was that was the
thing to do or what but I always just
figured it's better to have the screen
space for the code but you never know
maybe people people like that so it's
available if you want but it's on a
separate stream so if you don't want it
you don't have to see it okay so let me
go through just a few of the the changes
that I've made over the weekend and then
we're going to get into just continuing
to do some refactoring just like we had
done on Friday we're just kind of gonna
keep going through and clean things up a
bit and bring in as much as we can from
the WordPress API so that you know
everything everything that should be
editable will be editable from WordPress
I didn't run into a problem just two
minutes before I started the stream I'm
trying to you know I'm using advanced
custom fields in WordPress so let's see
I'm gonna show you I'll show you what's
happening and then maybe so if you look
at this this is the the program info
fields now we we created a field I think
I did this on the stream last I'm
actually created a field for URL and now
it's not showing up because when I tried
to add a field it came up with an error
and then when I went back into this it
had totally erased all the field so now
I'm afraid to go into any of them to
have all the fields erased
luckily this section this courses
section is not live yet so I know we we
had made it so that you could import
this would all be imported from
wordpress but i didn't want to put this
live with all the other stuff because i
didn't have all this data ready yet and
i hadn't actually tested it at all other
than just went through it a bit in the
live stream so for right now i'm gonna
refresh but it still seems like it's it
was working somewhat oh here we go no
it's not
so if you notice when there's a URL it's
supposed to show a link like a little
button to learn more so it's not so we
basically lost we've lost that data now
so I'm afraid to go into any other of
these these fields and try to change
anything because I don't want to get
that error I don't want to have
everything erase that would be that'd be
pretty bad I do have a backup of the
site so I backed up the site and then I
upgraded WordPress and I upgraded some
plugins that are were unrelated to this
so I'm thinking that something with the
update has messed up what's going on
with this plug-in so I'm gonna try to
recreate the area here so you all can
see it plus I didn't really have a
chance to look at it that well myself
since it happened
you're right before I had to start the
stream so let's just type in URL and
that's I'm not gonna type in explanation
now cuz it probably won't even work but
let's add this see if it works for us
okay so here's the air that we're
getting so it's saying
so it's in the advanced custom fields
plugin
see
so I'm not exactly sure what the problem
is and as you like I'm pretty sure I've
said this before I'm not really great
with PHP so I'd rather not have to dig
into this to figure out what the problem
is
so for now I think I'm just gonna leave
that since it's not on affecting the
live version of the site right now at
least I I sincerely hope it hasn't
erased all the data we should probably
should check it just to be sure let's
see let's bring this up let's try to
find some place that would have alright
so the resources would definitely have a
lot of custom fields ok so the
categories are by default WordPress that
shouldn't be a big deal but these are
okay alright so luckily this it hasn't
erased everything so what I'm thinking
would happen is if I actually went in
and tried to change any of other custom
fields in WordPress then it would erase
those as well so I'm gonna just gonna
leave this alone for now I'm gonna leave
this up on the screen I'm just gonna
move it over to the side and check that
out later on and try to figure that out
cuz I expect it's just gonna be a lot of
me googling things and I don't know
probably just commenting out lines of
PHP and so I figure out what the problem
is so that's that's not really gonna be
great great to watch but if anyone has
experience with advanced custom fields
with that plug-in and it seen anything
like that if you have any suggestions
let me know alright hey we got somebody
in the in the live stream on Instagram
so awesome so thanks thanks for check it
out I wondered if anybody would check it
out said one person also I realize it
may not be it may not be easy to get the
Instagram live stream right now
depending on you'll where you're at what
device you're watching this on obviously
if you're watching
the the coding stream on your phone
you're not going to be able to watch
another stream on Instagram Instagram at
the same time I'm gonna check the live
chat quickly since I haven't checked it
okay so Patrick says what some streams
with the face even though it gets in the
way either way it's fine
okay so it seems like the at least from
the people who have put in their opinion
it seems like that you all do agree that
the seeing someone's face just gets in
the way of the code anyway so so we'll
see maybe I'll do it again maybe I won't
so our nod seems to be very upset about
the face thing so so don't worry about
it or not just don't don't look at my
Instagram
vasya asks about the deadline for this
project yeah the deadline the for-sure
deadline this time I know there have
been multiple deadlines that have kind
of been like pushed back a little bit
that's how it goes sometimes you know
you you think you have a really hard
deadline and ends up not being like that
but the real deadline is I think I have
today and tomorrow to work on this and
then I'm done then I'm gonna start a
different project so Wednesday the
stream should probably it'll probably
end up being whatever the new project is
that I'm working on so okay Andrews
asking for me to post the the PHP error
and this is Andrew Ritter so I know
there's another Andrew that frequently
is on here but he could be in the stream
today so I'm posting everything it's
right now in the live chat oops
it's too many I'm gonna have to break it
up it was too many characters there's a
two hundred character limit for posting
in the live chat so there we go so the
first part fits the second part I think
the second part of the air is going to
be too long
yeah it's too long I'll have to break it
up which is gonna make it a lot harder
to read but I guess that's how it will
have to be for nah Wow okay so I'm gonna
grab I'll put it up on the screen just
for a second - so I'll just grab I can't
I want to grab all this but it's it's
over 200 characters so I guess I'm just
gonna have to do it maybe three parts
then
Jools saying you spaceman yeah I could
let's just do a paste yeah let me let me
get this out I'm not I'm not really that
worried about it for the stream so I
don't really want to take up all the
stream time over this error
I mean if worse comes to worst and I
can't use this i could just hard code
some custom fields i'd rather not do it
but because it would just be it would be
more work but if i can't get it to work
with the with the plugin then i don't
really have another option
okay all right so I did paste this into
Faceman
so now I put that link that links in the
live chat so if anybody does want to
check out that error I really appreciate
it if you if you know anything about it
but otherwise I'm going to I'm gonna get
started so we'll go through
let me bring over the my local version
and I'll go through just quickly just a
very minimal changes from what we had
worked on before in the dev site but
I'll show you what those are and then
we'll get right into we're pretty much
done with this page so I think events
will probably our next page that we
start refactoring and pulling in our
data with so I'm going to start my timer
and let's go alright so the home page
alright as always my dev server needs
restarted so obviously I still haven't
figured that one out
and if you want to check out any of the
changes in more depth
everything is on github and it is also
on the live version of the site the live
version of site is actually further
ahead right now than the than the dead
version then that the IP address for the
dead version so the khattak addicts com
the production version is where to go to
get the latest so anyway all this is
still the same the video changed they
wanted me to not use a youtube embed
because it had the YouTube branding and
it was showing ads so that's
understandable you don't want ads coming
up you know in the middle of your site
so I changed to use JW player
the only thing about JW player that the
only problem I've had and I didn't even
notice this until this morning was that
if I navigate away from it and go try to
go back it doesn't load again so um
there's a react plugin for JW player a
react component so I'm gonna try to get
that to work I just don't have the
account information for the account they
use JW player with so I'll need to get
that to be able to get the plug-in to
work so for now it does work on the
initial page load and it's fine there's
just a different you know different
image for the thumbnail that comes up
but I think it it's it works and they're
happy to people that I'm building this
site for happy with it these are all the
same everything else the same on this
page on the resources page that's
probably the the biggest change so I
pulled in these used to be on the bottom
like below this this section so this now
I think this was black the last time we
looked at it so I changed it to the red
background these are all white now this
section is now included in here so it
still works
the same way it's just the the colors
have changed and now it's within this
section and then for this I've made two
changes one categories only appear here
if they actually have resources attached
to that category so there were a lot of
categories that were put in that had
nothing attached to them yet so in the
response that we get from the wordpress
api it actually lists how many resources
are attached to that category so we can
just check that and if it's more if it's
one or more it shows up here otherwise
it doesn't so right now it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of categories but
there there are and that'll be that's
not something that I'm gonna be adding
in but hopefully the people in charge of
this content will be adding that in also
the problem that we had on non Mac
browsers I fixed that I just added in a
little bit of CSS that made sure that
these were always visible so they
weren't visible on some in some cases
like the the text was the same color as
the background just depending on the
browser and the operating system the way
this displays just it looks different on
between I think Firefox definitely I
think it what it might have been every
browser on Windows for sure looked bad
and then Chrome on a boon to so so I'm
pretty sure it was nearly every non
every browser running on a system that
wasn't a Mac was not displaying this
correctly you just couldn't see anything
so that's fixed now and I think that's
it for the the changes so not you know
not really a whole lot so now let's move
on to the events oh the only other
change which is minor I'm not gonna show
it is I add in a button actually I did
that on the stream on Friday so you
already know about that the
a change I made to that was I changed
the text for the button so they had
requested that I changed the text so for
this page we just need to we're gonna go
in here we're gonna pull in this day
that these we may make these their own
components so we'll see I'm not sure
that that needs to be I did have to edit
this a bit as well over the weekend on a
small screen these were like huge and
took up half so so these headers took up
half the screen they're really big and
so you could barely see any of this
content so I made it just added in some
media queries made it smaller maybe so
that they would wrap before they weren't
wrapping undo another line and then I
had to fix the the heights and here to
make them line up but I think it looks
it's way more readable now than it was
all right so let's check out the code
for this and I was trying to bring in
some data for this state weather
displays or not I was going to make this
this option to display the content or
not I was gonna make that a true or
false button within WordPress so that
whoever was entering the content could
set whether or not the content was
displayed by default or whether you had
to click to display it and that's when I
ran into that error so I'll come back to
that hopefully if I can fix that error
but for now let's go to or yet courses
no events we're gonna do events so let's
go to events and it looks like yeah we
aren't pulling anything in yet
except for those events down the bottom
there's nearby events so so we're going
to need to pull in that data
and let's see we got to decide I've I've
pretty much been assured that the only
there's always only going to be two
things here so the bosko conference
which is like the biggest events put on
by this this institute and then this
speaking the truth and love conference
they're always going to be at the top
here but I'm not really sure we probably
be safe to just make these pages and
pull them in and not have to make
another custom post type long term I
would suspect that maybe they would want
to put something else up here and have
more than two but since we're running
short on time I think I'll just leave it
as each one of these is going to be a
page so this will end up being event
intro event section 1 event section 2
and we'll just pull everything in from
there it's gonna be we're gonna have to
actually I don't know if we can right
now because we're gonna need some custom
fields to pull in some of these and if
our plugins not working we can't pull
those in so we can at least pull this
and for now and then we're gonna have to
hold off on this I may have this may
have to wait until after we fix that
plug in all right well at least let's
pull this in and then that way we'll get
some of the some of the code that we
need in place that'll make it easier to
do this later on so we'll go into
where's my WordPress I'm gonna open up
WordPress in another another tab since I
want to keep that error message up I
guess it doesn't matter since I put in
pay spin but for now I'll keep that up
and let's go in
and create these pages oh that's some
updates as probably things I am I
worried about updating themes we're not
really using them anyway so they'll go
into pages and make a new page it's
gonna be events intro so I think we've
been calling them intro and then now
let's yeah I'm just gonna copy this and
paste it in and that should be yeah
that's it that's all we need for this
one okay cool so we have our slug events
intro and that's what we're gonna want
to look for so let's go over to our code
and we're just gonna copy some of what
we've been doing on our other pages so
on the index page let's pull this over
here so we can see them both so an index
page we can just grab all of this
oops I'm already already have that and
threw me off because I had to state
above it so we don't need to copy that
but what we need to do is get
okay we are doing some filtering here by
date so I think that's okay we can still
we can still do that but we need to pull
in everything through this multiple post
type so let's put that first
so we need the multiple post type first
and then we need to grab the type
let's get rid of this that's what we
need nearby event so let's put in our
type equals nearby event and then we
also need I'm gonna put this at the end
just to make it more evident later on
that all these filters are really for
for this and I do want to see how this
how this data gets pulled back so I've
had some issues before with using
filters when I use this multiple loops
this multiple post type end point so I
do need type page
all right and I think let's just check
this out in the browser and see what its
gonna look like let's see if it even
returns anything okay cool so we are
getting a page
and
okay wow this actually worked a little
simple things okay I see so this is this
was the problem that I was running into
before so when I put any type of filter
on that end point it filters everything
so right now the pages are being
filtered as well as you know all of
these which are all the nearby events
are I'm sorry not not filtered but in
terms of what we get back from WordPress
it's filtering out all the things that
we don't need so I'm only getting title
in advanced custom fields okay so I do
need more than that so I'll need the
slug and I'll need the content as well
so that should be it as long as I get
the the slug and the content then that
should be fine so let's make sure we add
that in
okay
and I'm not gonna check it again because
I'm pretty sure that that will work so
now we're getting move this over so
don't need anymore so now we should be
getting all the data that we need we're
still gonna have all the events but in
addition we're gonna get all the pages
so we can grab the page that we need to
fill in this part all right so I will
bring this over briefly let's see
okay so we're gonna basically do this
same thing here so let's just grab this
and
I'm gonna paste this in now obviously we
don't want a blockquote for this section
so instead we're gonna do don't want a
pee thing no actually I don't I don't
even want a paragraph tag in here I want
they want to bring in this column
and let's pull out all this we don't
need this I'm gonna bring in this column
hmm
I thought I got rid of that I did it's I
guess it's just messed up because I
don't have a closing div for this so I
guess for now I'm just gonna put this in
I think it's gonna get taken out though
whenever prettier runs whenever we say
this it'll probably change that but for
now it'll just keep in my mind when I
see this it'll be easier to realize
where all the dips go we do want to put
flow text on here because we want that
font size and let's get rid of this we
don't need that and those content
rendered go study yep that's it that's
what we need the only other thing we
need to change is this so we're gonna
want to get events intro alright and
that should give us what we need let's
check back here on this page I guess it
did not give us who he needed I'm gonna
shadow refresh it just in case let me
see what's on it so at least these are
still showing up and my my dev server
needs restarted and as soon as I get
this working I'm gonna check the chat
again it's been about 20 minutes and so
check the chat
just a mess something up
hmm all right let's see what I messed up
here
let's go
alright let me read this object keys
Oh what did I do
Oh area that's the problem
I had this tag was actually closed and
it shouldn't have been closed it should
add all this in here now this will work
that's why my highlighting was off I
thought it was just it wasn't picking up
this tag but in fact that I had closed
that an opening tag
all right okay cool so this is loaded in
these are still loading properly awesome
now we are gonna need to change a little
bit about how we do this now so if you
remember I guess a few weeks ago we had
put in some things for instance we could
move this around and see I should still
working let's see maybe maybe we thought
ahead about this my fear was that this
would filter so these down here would
filter through all the the data
looks like it might still be I'm just
worried that the pages that we're now
getting up here will be counted in with
the events yeah so we're just getting
the data what are we setting - the data
the component did now
hmm
okay so we are getting the data we're
filtering it so that any old events
aren't displayed but so we may not have
to worry about filtering it because it's
possible that because the pages don't
have the advanced custom field of dates
that they're automatically getting
filtered out but I don't want to leave
it up to that in case that just seems to
me like it's not really an explicit
filter for those things and I'm a little
bit worried about it so let's put in two
filters and what I want to filter out is
and I'll probably need to get I'll need
to bring in type so we will need to get
the post type as well so we're pulling
them type in now that we're pulling the
type in I can access type so I want type
and I need it to equal and this is
nearby event I think it would just be
singular event we'll find out in a
second as soon as I save this okay looks
good I'm gonna do a refresh just to be
sure all right great
and to be really really sure we can
always inspect and go over to react and
we should be able to see our props
and let's see so we have our page prop
there but then this drops data
yeah actually our our props own ups I'm
sorry we're not the props are up here
and that's fine that this is everything
but we want to we want to set our state
of data then so the state should be what
only has the nearby events so let's see
it actually it's not showing me anything
about the state which is maybe I'm
missing and how do I see the state in
the react dev tools I know I've seen it
before I'm not sure why it's not showing
up now anyway it's it's obviously
working because we see this we see this
there's no crossover going on so in
terms of seeing pages here what we
shouldn't alright so that was good
timing now it's time to go back to the
live chat for at least five minutes
we'll see what's going on here all right
so I'm gonna go back up here
okay hey Sebastian Sebastian said I need
to add cursor:pointer to the course
title let's see
actually I do that I have it on there
I'm not working on let me check
oops
is it courses yeah actually it is
working here so I'm not sure is it not
working for you if so what what browser
and device combination are you using
alright hey everyone I see some people
saying hi hey
I'd have some questions so our play asks
did you work with react native I have
not worked with it yet I am going to be
working with it soon probably by soon I
mean sometime within the next few months
so I'm taking a react course through
Udacity and the last part of the course
is deals with react native so hopefully
when I do that part of the course I'll
share with you how it is and I'm hoping
that maybe I can have some sort of
project at work that I'll be able to use
react native with and then I could
stream that so that would be cool maybe
maybe I can do some type of video where
I go through react native for whatever
project that I'm doing for this course
I'll have to see I assume it would be
okay to stream stuff I'm doing for that
course but I mean it's a paid course so
I don't know if they want people
streaming course material so I might
have to double check on that just to
make sure it's alright but anyway yeah I
haven't worked with it yet but soon
soon I will be rollin said just got here
what's happening basically we're just
going through what we did last week the
end of last week just pulling in data
from the wordpress api trying to
refactor where we can and we had a
little bit of an issue or we have an
error coming up with one of our
WordPress plugins so that's limiting a
little bit what we can do but there's
still enough to be done that you can
definitely fill up the stream with other
things
okay so Andrew Ritter says sometimes
cannot modify header info has to do with
white space at the top or bottom of a
PHP file okay that's uh that's
interesting that's good to know
I don't I didn't manually edit a PHP
file so but I will check I'll definitely
check that out maybe I can manually just
look at the files and see if something's
going on in there I don't see why I
didn't update the advanced custom fields
plug-in was not actually updated
directly so I don't know that it's that
one I did update WordPress so it's
possible that something with the newest
version of WordPress is interacting with
the advanced custom fields plug-in but I
don't know I it's I did hold off on
updating WordPress for a while an
advanced custom fields is a really
popular plugin so you would think that
any issues would have been sorted out
but but anyway it's good to know Andrew
thank you
hey Zanna how's it going Suzanne has
joined us in the live chat says Jessie
you never read your Twitter while live
have you sent me something on Twitter oh
yeah I see it now
okay I saw I saw your message so yeah
that's true I don't always see what's
going on on Twitter on when I'm live so
I have my screen my third screen is
filled up with the analytics for the
chat or for the channel and in the chat
window so I don't really have them and
my OBS is up there so I don't have much
space for for Twitter and actually I
usually do see things that are going on
on Twitter on my phone but I have the
stream in what's Instagram so the
Instagram stream is blowing on my phone
so I'm not seeing anything which I don't
even think anybody is watching me on
Instagram so I suppose I could shut it
off but hey Jeremy how's it going
how Jeremy says always stoked to suggest
these vids I'm glad to hear I'm glad you
enjoy the videos
okay so having some some comments in
here about this air I'm gonna bring this
air back up in case someone didn't see
it from earlier since I'm gonna be
referring to it now so I'm having this
error or when I try to edit fields in
the advanced custom fields plug-in so
Sara says the first warning was about
for each and its same PHP page so header
and for each are the problem Zanna says
she's having a piece of cake actually
the cake sounds really good right now I
had I didn't remember to eat today so I
went out and bought sushi for lunch so
that was great but it doesn't really
satisfy a sweet tooth at all and I tried
nicely true I don't normally get like
the canned coffee stuff but there is a
cold brew canned coffee I don't know
about it I'm not sure there's anybody
know a good brand of cold brew coffee to
buy I like it when I make it myself I
haven't really found a store brought
brand like a ready-made brand that I
like they always have this weird
aftertaste
okay so John Hanson says html5 video tag
with source may be a better choice it's
easier to use with JavaScript when you
need an alternative to an embedded
YouTube video yeah I hadn't thought of
that
so initially so Friday I think it was
Friday afternoon or Friday night when I
got the the new embed code saying like
hey we don't want YouTube we want we
want this so my my first thought was
that that I would just download that
video and then do an html5 video tag but
I thought you know what it's worth a
shot just to throw this embed code in
and see if it works and I didn't expect
expected to work in the same way that
the YouTube embed code had worked
because it's not even the same you know
YouTube is an iframe and this one was
actually a script tag so I was really
skeptical of it and I'll bring it up
here since I'm talking about it so y'all
can see what I'm referring to you gotta
have it on my index page so this is what
what I popped in here in place of the
YouTube iframe and it actually worked
now unfortunately at the time I did not
realize that it didn't work when I was
using the client-side routing so I just
realized that when I started working
today and I was looking up some
different ways to to fix that so I may
end up going with that since I only have
today and tomorrow to work on it if I
don't hear back with the account
information for JW player then I'm gonna
have to go with the html5 thing the only
reason I didn't want to do that is
because it gives users a few more
options when you have like the embedded
player so they can pick different
qualities of the stream and things like
that and if there is any extras like
closed captioning then that's available
in an embed whereas I don't I have no
idea if you if you can do that with
html5 I assume there's some way to do it
but I don't know how and I don't really
have the time to do it so but anyway
John that was my first thought as well
so thanks for the
for the suggestion some of my other
sites I have known that route of using
the video tag
oh okay Sebastian reminded me I'm sorry
I I got a lot of good advice from you
all last week about how to fix my dev
server and then I didn't I did never try
it because so last week I had to if you
remember I had to leave like immediately
after I stopped streaming to go to a
meeting with a client so I completely
forgot what what you all said when I
came in this morning I didn't I hadn't
made I didn't even have time to make a
note of it anywhere so I'm really sorry
I'm over here talking about not being
able to fix my dev server when you all
already gave me plenty of things to try
so I apologize for that I'll try that
today I think I'm gonna work late today
my wife is gonna have the kids at her
parents house so I'm just gonna stay
after and work so I'll definitely have
time after the stream to work on that it
kind of stinks though that I'm finally
hopefully gonna fix my dev server and
then I'm gonna move on to another
project so but I kinda want to fix it
now just just to say that I've fixed it
and we've got one of my co-workers is
joining in on the Instagram live
livestream so so that's cool hey Liz
how's it going but all right so I see
I'm definitely gonna try to no Sebastian
gave me some advice I'm pretty sure
Patrick that you gave me some advice as
well okay Patrick did say I don't need
two filters I could just use you know an
and one actually I think we had talked
about this in an earlier stream and I
don't know if you were watching at the
time or not Patrick so I had I had
proposed you know should I just do an x'
or should I do the separate filters and
the the consensus was that you don't
need to do separate filters but it makes
it more readable so that's why I ended
up going with separate filters so I'm
gonna keep going with that since I've
got done
throughout the site at this point but it
is good to know for everyone if if
you're watching if you're you know using
filters like this you don't have to do
separate filters you can chain together
things in your filters this is just more
of a style decision
okay cool so I am earlier I had
mentioned that I wasn't I wasn't seeing
the state where's this in Devils so I
was just seeing props in that state and
several of you in the live chat have
told me that because I need to actually
click the component that has the state
to see the state so that that is my
problem and that's why I can't see the
state so you see I'm only seeing props
here so let me just try it while I have
so which component I don't even remember
which component I was trying to look at
oh here we go okay so if you're using I
don't know if this setup here is because
of next j/s that it's it's slightly
different so this I suppose this could
look different in terms of how you're
setting up reacting what you're using
with it but for me at least the state it
seems lives on this under slash class
element here so yeah okay this is
definitely what we're looking for so
right here you can see we only have ten
items in our array for data because we
filtered everything out whereas we
started with 26 items yeah we started
with 26 and now we've gotten filtered
down to 10 so that's filtering out
anything that's not a nearby event in
terms of type and also filtering out
anything that an event that has already
happened so it has a date that's in the
past okay awesome thanks for letting me
know because I I always that bothered me
that a cait sometimes I could see the
state and sometimes I couldn't and I
could only see props and that's why so
that's definitely gonna help me out now
okay so Ennis has said something in
another language so I'm not sure what
that is but thanks for for joining the
chat and let's see
okay so Sarah says Fred Meijer has good
cold brew so yeah I don't know I don't
think they have Fred Meijer around here
so I'm in Ohio so let's not all have to
keep a lookout for it but I'm pretty
sure that's not an option around here
but I appreciate the suggestion
okay so John says there is a way to
build my own html5 player with all the
stuff that I mentioned before like
closed captioning and things and being
able to pick the different options for
video quality but it does take a lot of
times yeah that would be really cool to
do I would enjoy doing that at some
point because I do everybody loves it
when I put like the fullscreen
background videos on sites around here I
don't know what it is but if I want to
impress somebody with a site all I have
to do is put a background video in and
and it's like they love it so that will
probably be a good thing to learn how to
do at some point
okay I'm getting towards the the end of
the live chat looks like there's some
discussion about live reloading and hot
reloading and webpack and different
things which I'm going to skip over for
now because it seems like there's a lot
of good information being being spread
in the live chat so I don't I don't
think my contribution to that discussion
will really be worth anything
wait so alright Jeremy says Fred Meyers
is owned by Kroger's really I did not
know that gets nothing
okay cool Rowland says Google has an
open source project that covers front
and back-end for video players that's
really cool and that's kind of
surprising because you think Google
would just say like go with go with the
YouTube embed but that's that's cool
that they have that and rhoann does say
by the way Safari and probably Firefox
will start to block a lot of place yeah
I do I know Safari will block autoplay
so I actually kind of just did a little
workaround for that but yeah I kind of I
don't like doing auto plays anymore I
have done them in the past but I've kind
of changed my mind on auto place and
decided that I think auto plays are
somewhat annoying so I right now like
I've gone more like what I've done with
this site in putting just a button to
play I still think there is a place for
auto plays to be used like I'm not
entirely against them but it can just be
annoying like I know for me sometimes
the videos just autoplay depending on
what the video is I can get motion sick
from the videos not not really I'm not
really into it I actually got sick I was
developing a site before where I had
full screen background video that would
kept audio autoplay and I kept getting
sick and getting headaches like at every
single day and I couldn't figure it out
and then finally I realized that the
reason that I was getting sick was
because of all this autoplay video
because I had to sign up on multiple
screens and I had it on a on a mobile
device as well so even in my peripheral
vision I was getting all of this
autoplay video going and it was just so
once I stopped doing that then I didn't
get headaches anymore and I didn't feel
sick anymore
all right so I my stream on Instagram
ended so if you wanted to see my face
too late not that not like anybody did
but I just wanted to tell you all that
in case somebody who was joining in and
and saw the link and wanted to watch
alright so let's go back to this so
basically at this point this is all
we're gonna do for this page or I'm
sorry we weren't on this page we're on
the events page this is all we're gonna
do for the events page this is the live
site where am I so definitely want to
pull this stuff in but need to fix that
plug-in first and I'm just so hesitant
to work on the plug-in because if it if
it deletes this the fields for the other
stuff then that's that's gonna be a
really big deal when it's gonna mess up
the live version of the site so I want
to be really really careful about how I
do that okay so the resources page is
going to be pretty easy we just need to
pull this in which is going to be
basically the same thing that we just
did with the events page we're gonna do
here so we'll go ahead and do it it may
be a bit boring let me start my timer
may be a little bit boring since we just
done it but especially for anybody who
might be new then repetition is always a
good thing to try to figure out how it's
done
all right so let's bring let's good idea
we don't need this I'm gonna get rid of
a lot of this stuff because don't say I
don't think I have anything important
there I have a lot of untitled pages so
I that has nothing in it all right I
don't need this anymore what is this I
don't need this anymore and I need that
okay this was from one of the earlier
live chats I think this is something I
brought over I don't need that okay
awesome so now I'll actually be able to
see what's going on up here and we'll
move the events page over so we can just
copy it over the code that we just used
here and resources okay so and our
resources and our initial API call we
need to just do the same thing that we
had done to the other one who want to
grab
this novel passe
we're going to say and type
equals resources the Titleist
I'm sorry I think it I think it's
singular as a resource how did we do it
over here yeah and then where else we're
gonna make sure that we get type and we
need title we're also going to need
content and we're gonna need slug okay
and then finally we need another type
equal page okay let me double check yep
page alright so we have that and then
now we're gonna set the state and for
this data when we set the state we
actually we want this table stated we
want to filter this and we're gonna do
the same thing we did before we're gonna
filter out those type loose
we have filter out those pages because
we just want the resources in here now
in the intro section that's here we can
copy and paste and this will be yeah we
can pretty much copy and paste this with
very minimal editing and since we have
the column already in there post that
and then all we have to do is say make
this the resource resources intro now I
don't really have that yet so it's not
gonna do anything so we need to go back
in WordPress and make a page a new page
the resources intro and ascitic
shouldn't have saved it first but i can
just grab it here and paste it in there
let's publish it and now let's try again
all right so that worked great and it
looks like everything's still working
down here
awesome okay so that page is done and
with the exception of that a little bit
on the events page and then those cards
on the home page that's everything that
we needed to pull in in terms of you
know data from the wordpress api that
needs to be editable so we still can't
make that live yet until I figure out
what's going on with this plug-in let me
see what else we could do let's check I
want to check this and catch us up a bit
I definitely spent another definitely
another Pomodoro session it was more
than one according to the timer but I I
don't want to I don't exactly want to
count them as equal and when I'm doing
the stream since I stopped you know
occasionally and answer questions so
what we need to do
Oh actually I know what I wanted to do
something earlier and I had completely
forgotten so now it's a great time to
show you so I had on fright I think it
was either Friday or maybe Saturday
morning I can't remember for sure
Patrick had submitted a pull request to
refactor the expanding section component
so the I think it was the last thing we
were doing on Friday was refactoring the
component are attempting to refactor
that and I didn't get it you know
finished completely so Patrick went in
and let's see of course you all can see
this you know for your cell phone on
github it's definitely available but I
just wanted to give give credit where
it's due here so you can see like how
much nicer this looks and you can see
this is just definitely like a much much
more lean component here way easier to
read so anyway so thanks Patrick I am I
merged that in over the weekend when I
was working on that and I really
appreciate appreciate that so and as you
can see it's being used right now on dev
the only reason that it's not on the
master branch yet is because I was I'm
just having issues with that with that
plugin as soon as I get those sorted out
then everything is going to be used in
the master branch on the production
servers
okay well I wasn't planning on doing any
PHP stuff but at this point I kind of
think I should I mean that's logically
just the next thing that is blocking me
from getting done what needs to be done
so if there are no vociferous objections
to me doing some PHP I'm going to so I
didn't I didn't plan on it but let's
just take a look at at what's going on
here so I'm gonna move this to my other
screen and I'm gonna bring up WordPress
I'm just going to go through for now at
least I'm gonna see if I can get to that
first file right from this admin panel
let me make this bigger all right so
what we're looking for is controllers
core controllers field group
looks like not seeing all right not
seeing yeah so I can't you can't always
see all the all the fields are all the
files that you need from here so it
doesn't look like I'm gonna be see gonna
be able to see it so this might be a
problem because I don't think I have
access to the files on this server
directly
but let's look up see if anything is on
here there we go there's something in
support it's a couple of things
as ODS because I wasn't attempting to
use the repeater field
that one wasn't helpful
yeah so this these are all talking about
the repeater field which I'm not even
using I don't think I can use the
repeater field unless I get the paid
version yep yeah not it all right I'm
gonna check let me check the live chat
quickly
no evil s what is that Bell so this was
right around 3:00 3:00 p.m. there's the
Bell so so as you all know I work at a
Catholic University so around 3:00 p.m.
and my building a lot of people from the
building get together and they pray
together for like 10 15 minutes at 3
o'clock so somebody rings a bell to do
the reminder for 3 so I obviously
haven't been able to do it in in that
because I do my live chats at 2:00 so
but they usually do they do a prayer
called a Divine Mercy chaplet 3 3 is
like 3 PM's the traditional time to do
that that prayer so that's what the Bell
is for so that's why you always hear
about at 3:00 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time
all right so I'm just going up quickly
just to see if I've missed anyone's
questions Patrick says autoplays evil
yeah
Joseph says hi I'm jr. frontend I don't
really understand what you're explaining
but I just keep listening to you because
your videos giving me more motivation
awesome well I'm glad that it's it's
helping you out in some way so yeah I'll
probably towards the end of the project
is probably more difficult to understand
what's going on but when I start up a
new project and it'll probably be way
easier for you to follow along and then
you know if you can if you can join in
on on you know most of the streams then
you'll be able to kind of work through
it all and understand everything
Sode says by the way which project are
you working in sir
I guess I'm assuming that that was of
trying to see if you were he was having
a conversation with somebody else said I
this is the same project that we've been
working in the katha catechol institute
react website so in particular though
right now we were trying to figure out
an error that we're getting with a
wordpress plugin and I was just taking a
little break to check catch up on the
live chat here since I wasn't really
finding much that was useful I guess I
should let's just pop in this and see if
something comes up your PHP no it's it's
still saying repeater PHP and and these
alright let me finish with what I was
going to do in the in the live chat here
Joseph says I wonder if it's possible to
see your previous livestream and and
Zanna answered so Thank You Zanna and
for anybody that can't see the live chat
yeah you can watch all the previous
streams on free code camps channel if
you want to go really far back to like
the first day I started working on this
site the first few videos are on my
channel which is linked in the
description if you wanted to start from
the beginning okay it looks like there's
there is a decent amount of discussion
about best practices in regard to
streaming videos and like because we're
talking about auto-playing videos and
things so it looks like there's Google
on Google Chrome's github there's a repo
called sample media PWA
and Rowin says that has a lot of good
streaming video best practices so so
check that out
I just saw I had asked if there was any
objections to doing trying to figure out
the error in WordPress and I just saw
Janet said I object but she was kidding
those surfers Patrick cave the
definition of vociferous yeah is that
was it that's a decent word right
vociferous not don't really use it too
often but it fit Patrick says he is a
vociferous opponent of PHP in general
but not in this case so all right good
all right Sarah saying three from bottom
looks like it might be helpful and I
probably changed the page before I saw
that so let's see once
I might have to hit back
so let me go I'm just gonna open up a
few more of these and see if any of them
work
oh this is do you see this this is
ridiculous
so warning you know the title of this
thing just has it there's no explanation
and just problem solved that's so
helpful and being really sarcastic
sorry I didn't upgrade so that's not
really
mm-hmm I don't think that even has
anything to do with it
no I don't think that's not the same
issue
all right let's I want to try want to
try something
okay
all right so it doesn't matter what I do
or what let me change the field type I
was trying to get an idea for like what
this
hmm yeah it doesn't matter field group
PHP
yeah so I can't add anything now I
really this had to have had something to
do with updating
let me figure I need to I really want I
want to look up which version of
WordPress I'm using right now you see if
there's some type of issue
before point eight
okay
let me I'm gonna pull in some in this
area no arguments
who won't see it as the repeater field
this is always what happens
see
I wonder
well at least I'll be able to see what
what's in this part of the file was on
that line
all right so this is the line is
throwing the air
and Nan says it's one o'clock in the
morning here in India and I'm staying
awake to see this livestream you're a
great inspiration thanks for this man I
really appreciate that
I think it's amazing that you're staying
up to watch me do this dream and yeah
thanks for saying that
I I'm happy that my stream is its
inspiration to you and yeah that makes
me anyway I when I hear stuff like that
I do really appreciate it makes me want
to keep streaming yeah someone had said
earlier lefty said earlier there's
always time to pray so yeah that is
definitely true yeah so I do miss the
prayer at 3 o'clock which a chemist
thing I I did kind of like you know
getting together with everybody and
praying it's kind of nice because
sometimes you know you don't always get
along with all your co-workers but it's
cool to come together you know and pray
for each other so kind of helps helps
get through all the the tension of
normal workdays but but there's
definitely other times throughout the
day for prayer
car I'm sorry I don't
Musharaf pronounces cart car needs cook
says hello is there a series where you
start to hook up your project to
WordPress yes so I don't know about a
series but there's definitely a video
where I hook things up to WordPress and
I don't remember offhand what the title
of that video would be but I'm pretty
sure if you check out this plet the live
coding with Jesse clay list on free code
camp and just look for the titles that
say WordPress then it'll be one of those
and I'll show a show a little bit about
how I set up WordPress about how I pull
in data and things like that I'll
probably end up doing some sort of
tutorial video on my own channel about
that because that would be I want to
like do tutorial videos to show how all
the sites that I make for for this
university work and then that way if
someone else if something happens to me
and someone else needs to work on the
sites then they'll be able to see what's
going on from the videos and hopefully
it can also help other people who are
doing similar projects elsewhere to kind
of just see how I did things okay so I
think
my here it is all right so let me see
it was talking about the the post ID
this was wait I mean this looks why
would the post IDs be be the problem
the thing is - I think this file itself
has not undergone any changes for like
two years I think I think that's what it
said
I really hate to restore the backup
because I I did add things and let me
see what where that when the last backup
is because I added a lot of data in and
I think it was all done after I backed
it up
I hate to have to add that in add it
back in again but I'm not sure you know
what I don't really think that I have
the access that I need to try to fix
this because really what I really want
to be able to do is check out I mean I
could see this with this file supposed
to be doing but I want to be able to see
this file and right now I don't have
access to that file so I need to I need
to talk to the guy that setup the server
and that's one of my co-workers set it
up I need to talk to him and get access
to this and see what's going on
all right so
yeah for uh probably for this dream I
think now I'm just I'm gonna go to the
live chat I'm gonna take some questions
and then I'll probably wrap this dream
up because I want to be able to talk to
my my colleague about this this plugin
error before he leaves I don't want to
make him stay late trying to figure this
out so I left the end I know I kind of
plan on doing this dream until 4:00 it's
3:30 so it'll probably end around there
depending on how many questions I get
anyway so I guess it'll be about the
same length as normal so I feel this
just feels like a weird stream it's been
a bit frustrating I guess I it's a
little bit different I tried to do some
different stuff at the beginning and
then ended up ended up with this getting
an error two minutes before the stream
started so a little bit of a weird
stream hopefully somebody got something
helpful out of the stream which seemed
like a few people said at the very least
they got inspiration out of it so I
guess that's just how it goes
some days you just you just have
problems so that we could get some
things accomplished and so if anyone has
any questions now would be the time to
put them in the live chat or you can
direct message me on Twitter you can put
it in the comments for this video and
I'll get to them as soon as I can
right now I'm gonna scroll up a bit in
the chat i'ma go through and see if I
missed anyone's question and don't worry
if you're new like don't worry about
asking questions that you think might
not be a good question or it might be
kind of like a noob question to ask
don't I it does not bother me you can
ask me ask me whatever you want even if
you think it's a silly question
I'm definitely beginner-friendly in
terms of the questions here nobody is
going to nobody will ridicule you if you
ask a beginner question
oh yeah I just went up up to the top of
the stream and I saw so Jeremy was in
the stream Jeremy I don't know if you're
still there but yeah you you just got a
new job
how is it going did you start yet I
can't remember if you started a job yet
if so and you're still watching let me
know how it goes otherwise maybe I'll
catch you tomorrow or sometime later
this week in the stream and we can get
an update on the new job
oh yeah I forget to tell you all so last
week on Friday I ended the stream was
gonna go right to a meeting with a
client so the client never showed up
turns out that she had emailed me while
I was streaming and I didn't see the
email so I had gotten so many emails
during the stream they got pushed down
in my inboxes normally I'll check at
least I'll see him come up on my phone
as I'm streaming and I can see if
there's something important well I just
got too many emails right around the
same time and it didn't even show up in
my notifications that had already been
pushed down so anyway so I had rushed to
the place where I was supposed to meet
and she didn't come luckily that place
had good Wi-Fi
well I wouldn't I don't know if it was
good Wi-Fi but it was good enough Wi-Fi
for me to get a do a little bit so I was
able to to at least get a few things
done while I was waiting before I saw
the email that she wasn't gonna be there
so I had a little bit of coffee and did
a little work so it wasn't wasn't a
complete waste inside wasted time to go
but now I still have no idea what's
gonna happen with this potential client
in this project so I'll keep you all in
front informed we might meet this Friday
so we'll see we'll see how it goes but
it's not really a good sign for a client
if they if they bail on the first
meetings it's not not really sure that
this is a Frederick that I want to work
on
okay I'm scrolling down I'm getting down
towards the bottom of the live chat so
it looks like I had kept up pretty well
with with the questions and you all do a
great job on the live chat of answering
everyone's questions - most of the time
you answer the question is better than I
could before I even see them
okay Patrick I just saw your comment
when I was I pointed out you know that
Patrick kid had done the pool request
refactoring that big component so and
Patrick says happy to do it it was a fun
exercise and refactoring so well I'm
glad you had fun doing and I do I very
much appreciate the help that was those
really awesome and when you all send
that pool requests like I always learned
so much from them so I always look I go
line by line I check out what you which
you've done and not that I don't trust
you it's more for me because I learned
so much just seeing how you do things as
opposed to what what I had done and just
learning a lot by how you improved it
I'm I'm amazed at how much more I
learned from looking at your pool
requests then I I've learned from just
looking at code or you know it's it's
it's just a different thing when you see
somebody else's take on your code trying
to solve the same problem that you had
and just making it doing in a better way
just it's really really helpful just way
more helpful and in educational than I
ever thought it would be
ooh Tom asks is there any SAS tutorial
video from free code can't I don't I
don't know offhand I haven't done a
video so I know for sure that I haven't
done a SAS tutorial video for free code
camp I think I have used tonight you
says I think I use some sass and some of
my earlier videos but it certainly
wasn't a tutorial it was just me using
it so I don't know I'm sorry I can't
I don't remember offhand if there is any
videos on free code camp but free the
free code camp YouTube channel has a lot
of videos so there's certainly playlists
that I have not checked out so there may
be something in there but I just I don't
know so if anybody else has ever seen
anything on free code camps channel
about sass please let us know in the in
the live chat or in the comments of this
video or again I know I have seen other
tutorial videos for sass elsewhere so
there are definitely some good ones
which I'm like who uses
I can't remember what I've seen really
good ones but when you're talking about
SATs I assume you mean like the scss
version of SAS and not like the original
success that is just all like
indentation if you want to know about
the original SAS that is different it
let's say more different from CSS then s
CSS so I confused myself with all this
then travis has a guy named Travis does
a youtube show called dev tips and I
know he's done videos on that but he
does use kind of like the the older
version of sass which doesn't have any
like punctuation everything's done with
indentation so may not be what you want
because I don't think very many people
use use that format that much at least I
don't see it very often I I have used it
for a project the only thing I don't
like about it is it's not you can't just
copy and paste in regular CSS from
somewhere and have it work with s CSS
you can and that's that's kind of a big
deal especially if you're using a
framework for a project because off
frequently you know you need to just
copy in pieces of stuff so anyway sorry
I can't remember any other videos other
than that
okay Patrick also mentioned def chip dev
tips channel okay Patrick prefers the
SAS format versus s CSS yeah honestly I
wish I wish that you could that there
was some way to copy in regular CSS into
SAS and then I probably would still use
the just the like regular SAS format
instead of s CSS because it's so fast to
type which is the indentation I really
really like that it'd be cool if maybe
you there was just some type of tag like
and if you put something inside that tag
then it could be regular CSS and it
would work you know to break the flow of
the normal thing I don't know if that
would be possible to put in or something
but that would be that would be cool
that would make it ideal for me and I
would I would still use it I think
Rohan says he prefers s CSS over SAS but
probably is because the muscle memory is
trained trained for semicolons yeah
that's true Rowan says I thought s CSS
and SAS are developed in parallel yeah
I'm not really sure that might be read I
always just assumed that SAS was the
older of the two but I might be mistaken
now what I think about I'm not really
sure where I learned that from it was
probably just an assumption on my part
Jay asks hey Jessie which do you prefer
react or angular and why so I do prefer
react but I will say I don't think I am
experienced enough with angular to have
a very good opinion about it so I think
they're both really good for what they
do
for me I've had an easier time learning
react I tried to learn angular a few
years ago probably more than a few at
this point maybe
like three or four years ago and I
didn't have it wasn't that easy for me
to learn and I wasn't able to really
make anything great with it so but I
my experience with JavaScript in general
was like really minimal at that point I
wasn't that good with it so that
probably is why I didn't have a very
easy time with it but I think react is I
like react because it seems pretty easy
to to pick up on you don't need to learn
a lot of extra stuff it seems like most
of it I know there is some this huge
debate on Twitter recently about saying
that things are just JavaScript and I
don't want to get into that whole debate
but like saying that react is a lot of
just JavaScript is a lot of it is like
normal JavaScript syntax you don't need
to learn all this extra stuff when I
don't know what angular is like now but
angular felt it felt like there was a
lot more like the templating syntax that
was specific to angular that I needed to
learn but like in react JSX works just
like normal HTML the tags are all really
the same and in terms of like when I
want to do more templating stuff like I
use template literals which are a part
of JavaScript so it seems like when I'm
developing with react I use more of
things that are already built into
JavaScript to get things done when I was
working with angular I always had to
look up the angular way to do things
like even things like iterating over
elements or something like that
there was like an NG - something that
did everything so I liked the fact that
react with react I'm not just learning
the react way to do things but I'm
learning JavaScript ways to do things so
that I could use with other projects
that I'm not using react on so I kind of
like that
I like the fact that react works like
react can be rendered to other things so
you know you can use react native to
build mobile apps you can go desktop
apps you can even do VR stuff so that's
kind of cool I really like all of that
so anyway but as I said I don't I
haven't used any of the newer versions
of angular so I don't think it's really
a fair comparison on my part between the
two because I don't have any knowledge
at all of any of the newer stuff but
anyway I hope that answers your question
and I know I've talked about this before
previously but it looks like Karl asked
a similar question hey Jesse after
learning Jay s do you recommend react or
angular so the similar question not
exactly the same the first one was what
do I prefer the second one is what do I
recommend so yeah and you asked it like
in terms of after learning Jaso after
learning JavaScript do you prefer react
or angular I I actually don't think you
need to wait until after you learn
JavaScript maybe it seems like that's
implied in the question at least implied
that you're saying you you're gonna
learn jobs here first and then go to a
framework I don't think you need to and
here's the here's how I feel about
learning JavaScript in everything like
if you're trying to work and make money
like if you need to pay the bills if you
have to support your family or something
like that like we can't talk about the
idea if we want to talk about the ideal
situation of what should you learn when
and in what order like we can talk about
that all day if we want to but there
aren't very many people that are in that
ideal situation where they get to spend
all their time learning and don't have
to worry about actually like fulfilling
requirements from clients and things
like that so my advice would be learn
what you have to learn to pay the bills
you know and to to make your clients
happy
and don't worry about saying I want to
learn all of JavaScript first I'm not
saying that's what you mean by that
question but just in general I would say
to anybody starting out don't worry so
much about saying the guy you know I got
to learn vanilla JavaScript I don't want
to mix with anything that'll come if you
want to pick up right off the bat egg do
some basic JavaScript enough so that you
can start to understand react and I
would recommend react and for reasons
mentioned above like I've just had a
much easier time doing it and you do
learn a lot more in my opinion you learn
a lot more of regular JavaScript stuff
when you're doing things with react and
you have less of you know really and
react in terms of react only stuff it's
really like the component lifecycle
functions and things that's the only
like react only way of doing things that
I've seen so anyway I would recommend
going to react and I would say like
don't as soon as you can start to
understand react and build things with
it then go for it
you'll pick up a lot of the JavaScript
like for me I picked up so much
JavaScript like I had never used filter
or map before I used react I had built a
ton of stuff I have I've built websites
using javascript for years before I ever
used react and I never use filter or map
so those are like things that I use
constantly now that I did not use before
I mean that's just one example but my
javascript skills have increased while
I'm learning react so if I would have
waited and said I'm gonna learn all this
stuff it probably would have taken me a
long time and now at this point I'm
getting better with JavaScript but I
also now know how to use react so I
don't think they have to be separate I
think you can you can move into it at
the same time and I think just in
general you shouldn't worry so much like
about the order of learning things like
unless you're in the unique situate
of saying I don't have to worry about
making money I have all the time in the
world I can try to do this the perfect
way
well then maybe maybe you do want to go
in order of mastering plain vanilla
JavaScript first but I don't I don't
really know that there's much merit in
that I think that you're fine to just go
right into a framework and then and I
would recommend react in in that case
okay Patrick asks also in in regard to
those last two questions definitely in
the live chat now or in the comments and
the video later on please I invite you
know any anyone watching this to join in
that discussion as well as I said I
don't have a lot of experience with
angular so I would appreciate someone
who maybe has more experience with both
giving their opinion on that Patrick
asked what was the name of a newsmen
park you took your kids to I went to
some near you as a kid but don't
remember the names yeah actually it was
called Idlewild it's in Ligonier
Pennsylvania so it was a there signs up
all over Idlewild saying that it was
voted the best children's amusement park
in the world which I don't know I'm not
really sure like how that who votes for
that right but anyway it is pretty good
X if you're anywhere near Pennsylvania
and it's Ligonier is kind of near
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania so it's in the
like the south western corner of
Pennsylvania but if you're anywhere near
there and you have kids definitely check
it out it's really cool there's a water
park and an amusement park so there's a
lot of rides the smaller kids can ride
to not really like very many big roller
coasters or anything so if you're into
like really fast scary roller coasters
that's not really the place to go
but if you have little ones that can't
ride those kind of rollercoasters anyway
Idlewild it's a place to go if your kids
like mr. Rogers or like Daniel Tiger's
neighborhood they have a whole like you
can take a ride on trolley and they take
you into Daniel cider Tigers
neighborhood and really cool like my one
of my my sons is he's about to turn
three next week and he loves Daniel
Tigers so that was super fun taking him
through the ride on trolley so been
anyway really cool my only complaints
about the entire place or the the food
is so expensive which i think is normal
for amusement parks like you get in
there and like they charge you like
double which you would normally pay for
something and it's not even good so the
food is expensive and not really that
good I didn't I didn't like that also it
was weird they had they were playing
music at various like parts of the park
and the some of the music had profanity
in it and it's like this place is
marketed as a family-friendly like
little kids theme park and I thought
that was odd that they would choose to
play music like that around around
children
so other other than those two things I
have no complaints I've been there I
went there when I was a kid and now I've
I've taken my kids there for a few years
now so anyway totally not related to
coding but it may be useful to youth if
you're near Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Alberto says traversée media also has
videos web dev videos and I'm assuming
that this is in regard to the videos
about sass Oh Sara says try level up
sucks yeah you're right yes Sara they
definitely have videos on that I totally
forgot about them
I John Hansen says I you sass love it
best way to learn it is to use node sass
in production with a linter it's the
fastest way to learn it yeah that's what
I think that's how I had it set up as
well yeah I normally do you sass I just
didn't never set it up for this project
so in future projects I'll most likely
be using sass so if you're interested in
learning more about sass it will be
coming
well okay rollin looked it up and said s
CSS and sass syntax are being they're
developed in parallel so that's cool
when they actually have four different
styles that's cool I never really okay
and so sass is the original syntax and
it's still supported and then s CSS is a
CSS compatible format and it's the
default format for sass three and up so
okay cool so I wasn't just making it up
it was that that was actually then so I
was I was mistaken and the fact that I
didn't realize that it was still being
developed but it was the original one
all right Amelio asked it's a question
that could be difficult to answer but
how much money does an advanced front
end of make an hour all right so I don't
yeah this is going to be difficult to
answer obviously as as everyone knows it
does depend on you know where your
location is and things like that and
also I don't know that I would consider
myself an advanced front-end dev so I
can't speak from experience to that but
I will say my hourly rate ends up so I
make a salad salary so but I have
calculated my hourly rate before and I
think if you factor in I think if you
factor
depending on whether or not you factor
in my benefits and things like that I
think I make between thirty and forty
dollars an hour for what I do right now
and that's like assuming that I'm not
working any extra which currently I am
working a lot of overtime that I don't
like it's not I don't really make extra
money for overtime so yeah so right now
it's somewhere between thirty and forty
dollars an hour for me
freelance I can make more than that so
now of course when you're freelancing
like there's there's a whole there's all
kind of extra overhead that goes into
things that makes it not as desirable I
guess like you you know you have to
handle all your business taxes and
client invoicing and contracts and
things so there's extra headache that
goes with that but I would say like as a
freelancer depending on who the client
is like if they're nonprofit or not and
what kind of work I'm doing it would
fluctuate but like right now I would I
probably even for a non-profit
I wouldn't think about taking any
project that would be like below fifty
dollars an hour and I don't even know if
I would go that low but right now I'm
really busy I don't have a lot of time
if I had more time I don't know maybe I
think about it or if it was a really
good cause and they didn't have any
money I would maybe think about corn
lower but realistically for like a
business client like my price range per
hour is is around a hundred a hundred
dollars an hour if I lived in a like a
big city it would be higher than that
but the area that I live in has a pretty
low cost of living for in terms of like
the United States standard of living so
I think I can get away with that but if
I was in a bigger you know if I was in
San Francisco I doubled
for sure I don't know if I could make
that or not but the cost of living there
is so much more expensive I would
definitely go more so I don't know if
any anyone else has anything that to add
into that but that's been my experience
personally with you know pricing and
things and I know there's like it's hard
to find like reliable data I've seen a
lot of studies and different things
about like what do front-end devs really
make but I always just wonder how
reliable it is so I'm not sure but
anyway Emilio I hope that helped to
answer your question a bit I will say
this so you did ask about an advanced
front-end dev but I think it might be
helpful to talk about like it just
starting out and say like when I was
just starting out I worked for $10 an
hour doing like I guess it was kind of
front-end dev work it I did like barely
any like JavaScript coding and more like
some basic like CSS HTML stuff but I
started out at dollars an hour so
there's definitely quite a range
all right cool I just saw Jay said
Jessie thanks for your great advice I'll
get with react now all right cool
yes I mean I'm not like I said I don't
think I'm an expert with reacting for
sure I'm not an expert with angular but
yeah I do
I am confident enough to recommend going
with react I think you'll be you'll be
happy with it there's a lot of jobs for
react developers right now so I've had
fun using it so far Rowen says you never
completely learn anything in a coding
world there's always new things changes
etc there are features like map and
reduce that are es6 plus and that you
will be fine without knowing them yeah
that's definitely true I hadn't even
thought of that but realistically like
javascript is a changing language so
it's it's not even a reasonable goal to
say you would want to learn you know
let's learn JavaScript like you don't
just learn JavaScript
because it's changing and so you could
never just learn it and have know it all
oh cool so Patrick has been to the same
amusement park that I took my kids do so
cool it's uh there are parts of it that
have not changed at all since I went
there when I was a kid and then if
they've certainly added a lot on since
then but it's kind of cool that there
are still parts that look exactly the
same
Rowan says amusement parks and movie
theaters charging ten times the price
for stuff not worth the original price
that's for sure yeah to me it's like I
mean I realized like as a business
they're just trying to make a lot of
money but I wouldn't I wouldn't be as
upset if the food that they charged so
much for was really good like I don't
mind paying money for things that are of
good quality and they're worth the money
but if you're charging more and then the
food is just bad it's like bet that
upsets me like obviously like they
you're paying enough that they could get
better quality ingredients
you know they but they don't jordan asks
what about less so if you're not
familiar with less or sass for that
matter those are CSS preprocessors so
basically it's it's a way to let you do
things to help you write CSS faster and
do things that you normally can't do in
CSS like have variables and do different
types of you know like things that are
closer to which you can do in a
programming language but being able to
do it with CSS so less is one type of
preprocessor sass is another type of
free processors so some people you says
some people use less I personally have
never used less so I can't really
comment too much about it it seems like
the trend is towards sass so if you are
gonna start to learn something now I
would say go with sass but you know for
instance bootstrap the
popular you know library like CSS
framework library is they used to use
less and with the newest version of
bootstrap they're moving to sass so like
you know things like that where you know
big frameworks are switching from less
to sass leading me to believe that sass
would be the better way to go but I've
even heard people talk about not even
using that anymore that CSS as a
language is starting to support things
so I think sass will still be useful for
years enough people use it in projects
that it's not going to go anywhere
anytime soon
at some point yes regular CSS will
probably catch up and browsers will
catch up and perhaps you won't need the
things that sass can do but for now at
least I though I still think is pretty
useful
Sahra asks what would be the best way or
resource to start learning react after
learning basic JavaScript
I guess code Academy has a beginners
course on react free code campus react
stuff Udacity has a course and reacts
that that is paid the the first two are
free those would be good ways to start
out with and react create react app and
the react documentation are a great ways
to get started in it if you need certain
features like server-side rendering or
routing built in you could start with
next Jas and it helps you kind of get
started without having to learn all the
you know web pack and and things which
can be kind of confusing at first there
are a lot of good videos on react so
those are my it's not super specific of
a list but I think those are good ways
to start out with and there's somebody
last week at some point in a live chat
somebody posted a link to a great
resource on git
that had all these different things to
learn I believe it was react I can't
remember what that link was though it's
possible I still have it up on my
computer somewhere but I have a lot of
tabs and windows open so I hope maybe if
I can find it I'll post it in the
description for this video I can't
promise that I'll be able to find it
because that's possible that I closed it
out and but I do think I starred that
repo I did start it so yeah so maybe
I'll try to find it among when I start
repos and post it in the chat and if you
want to you can send me a message a
direct message on Twitter to remind me
about that and then I can just send you
the link to that resource as well if
you'd like
my guess what would you give for the
hundred dollars per hour I mean what
level of a site okay so yeah so the site
if it was $100 an hour I mean probably
this type of site that I would be doing
would be like a react site and that's
why it to me at this point $100 an hour
that it's not so much of a level of like
this is this is what you would get but
more of that's what that's what it would
take to make it worthwhile for me to
take more time because I already have a
full time job that's more than full time
often you know I'm often working extra
and I'm taking a course on the side and
I have some some clients on the side
that I'd be recurring work for you know
and I just I already wish I had more
time for my kids and my family and so
for me to even consider taking any more
time away from my family to do something
it would have to be worthwhile in terms
of bringing in more money for my family
like a reasonable amount of money so
that I could in my mind I could say well
I'm gonna make at least make their lives
a little bit better by bringing in this
money and it's it's probably a poor
trade-off I don't know if this is the
right way to think about it but it's
like well if I can't be with them for
that hour like I at least want to be
able to say like I'm gonna provide some
security for them or be able to give
them something that you know it's gonna
at least make up a bit for that and I
got to think like well I need to be able
to pay someone to like take care of my
let my lawn you know cut the grass or do
repairs on my house because I'm gonna be
working and I won't have time to do that
so it's not so much like I wouldn't
explain it like this to a client but for
my point of view the price that I said
is like what is it going to take to get
me to do that
from and if a client wants to pay me
that much they're gonna recognize like I
really want this guy to do my site
because he's good or whatever and what
is it gonna take for me to get Jesse to
do my site now if I was really going
after clients which I'm not and I was
trying to market myself to clients I
would put it in terms like this is the
value that the site's going to bring to
you like you're gonna get so many more
customers you're gonna sell so many
units of this product or service and so
this site is gonna actually bring you
you know let's say this much money like
let's just say like this sites gonna
bring you in another like 50 thousand
dollars a year and you're only gonna pay
me ten thousand dollars or something so
I'm gonna bring value so if I had to
explain it to a client in terms of value
I would explain it like that but you
know in terms of my own motivation for
it it's entirely based on like I just
don't have that much time so it needs to
be worth my while for me to work on it
so it's kind of an odd I don't know it's
kind of an odd situation when I was
freelancing it was it was a different
thing it was like I need to set a price
that's fair for me but it's still
competitive so that I can actually get
clients so there's a whole different
ballgame but when when you have enough
work I really feel like the only
reasonable way to set your price is like
what's my time worth to me and the
busier you are the more your time is
going to be worth so my my rate of what
I'm willing to work for change is based
on how busy I am
but I will say when I get when I get
paid well to do a job I I do a good job
I'm obviously not just in it for the
money like I want to work on projects
that are things that I'm interested in
and I want to do a really good job on
them so I don't really feel bad about
charging more because I think people are
getting a really good product from the
work that I do hopefully that answered
your question Mike dono asks can I get a
job after completing front-end so I'm
assuming that means like the front end
certificate from free code camp I've
heard of a lot of people I guess I don't
know a lot is a relative term but I have
I know that there are people who have
gotten jobs after completing the front
end certificate so obviously it's not a
guarantee that you can get a job but if
you check out the free code camp forum
you'll see stories of people that have
done just that and I would recommend
that check out their stories see kind of
what they did how they went about trying
to find a job after they completed the
certificate and that'll give you a
better idea of if that's you know how
close is their experience to your
experience you know and give you a
better idea what your chances are
realistically of getting a job but but
it definitely happens people do get jobs
after the completing the front end
certificate rhoann does says freelance
depends on area of expertise location
experience connections yeah don't
underestimate the connections thing your
your freelance the amount of work you
can get and how much you can charge is
definitely depending on your connections
my best clients were just came from
connections
Emilia says thanks Jessie I've set my
projects very low so I would take your
advice I mainly do WordPress sites with
strong design okay cool yeah hopefully
and I mean it's it's it's hard to set
your rate based on what other people are
doing especially if they're not in the
same market and to like geographically
years so I guess the best thing that to
do would be try to figure out what
people in your own area are charging or
or in like the area that you're
targeting because you you know you can
do remote work for people somewhere else
like I ended up doing remote work mostly
for people in around New York City
because I could charge more and they
that was a reasonable thing around where
I was at people would freak out if they
were gonna pay me $100 an hour they just
didn't understand the cost of a quality
website and the value of it so I just I
completely just quit trying to get
clients in my own area because it wasn't
worth my time you know to try to put in
all the effort to get a new client and
make a contract and all that stuff and
have preliminary meetings when they
wanted to spend you know $200 and get a
website you'll get an e-commerce website
for $200 with you know that's just if
they wanted that that's fine but I
wasn't gonna be the guy that was going
to do that for him
okay all right there's some links so
hopefully we had some people ask about
react and there's been some some links
put in there so there's some github
repos so once called awesome react
another repo is react Redux links so
search for those on github and this will
have a lot of information for you about
resources for learning react
alright so Mike says okay that makes
sense I would love to go into doing some
freelance just do not know where to be
in finding clients alongside the two
companies I'm already running and I'm
terrible pricing yeah it it takes a lot
I think it just takes time to get good
with trying to estimate prices like just
experience and to get the confidence to
be able to go in and say like you know
this is how much it's gonna cost and it
was it was really tough for me at first
starting out you know it's for all that
stuff and it does it helps a lot now
that I
I don't like need the money in it really
helps helps you be a lot more confident
when you're in negotiations with a
client like to just say like hey this is
this is my price take it or leave it
and be confident knowing that you could
walk away and you'd be fine you can
still pay all your bills but that's I
don't know that there's anything you can
just do to get good at that right away
it's just it just takes time
Emilia says I now charge two thousand US
dollars approximately for a wordpress
site that has some heavy design on it in
some functionality that's cool yet and I
would say especially with WordPress
sites I thereof I have seen freelancers
like seeing their websites where they
have it set up that that they'll charge
a certain amount of money per WordPress
site and they have it like very
structured to say like the client owes
them this amount of money and this
content and these materials by a certain
date and then they deliver on a certain
date and any deviation is not allowed in
the contract like it's in the contract
and so that they are really and they're
booked up and they know exactly what
work they're going to be doing for
months in advance and if a client wants
them to do the work they have to meet
the requirements in terms of getting the
content and the payments in on time
that's really a nice set up and then you
know you can do a wordpress site for
$2000 if you have it like that the the
problem I found sometimes is you do a
site and you have a client that drags
their feet you know they're they don't
get you the right content needed or they
don't get back to you with important
questions that you know you need the
answers to for a really long time so
that a site that should have taken you
know a small amount of time and all of a
sudden drags out it's months and months
and months and it messes up your other
projects it's hard to so I suppose I
wouldn't be as opposed to doing like
smaller sites if I had some type of
structure set up like that to where I
knew I would I would turn over sites
quicker I I mean if you're gonna do know
it just is just basic math right if
you're gonna do smaller sites for less
money you need to be able to do a lot of
them or you could try to go for really
big projects they're gonna be a lot of
money and you know take up months and
months to do them so either way I like
if you need to pay the bills you take
whatever you can get and I've been there
and
but I think Emilio I think that's not
bad you know $2,000 for WordPress site
as long as you can you know get the
site's finished quickly enough you know
that's that's good money
rohan says a good recruiter will value
modern online learning tools like free
code camp udemy etc free code campus
trusted yeah this was in regard to the
question about can I get a job with the
free code camp certificate and that's
true yeah I think some companies still
like don't realize how things are well
in terms of like developers in their
education and they still require you
know traditional degrees and stuff but a
lot of newer companies tech companies
and things they understand how things
really work and that it's much more
important that someone can do the work
and so you're you're more likely to get
a job with a certificate for free code
camp at one of those type of companies
then maybe like kind of you're more
old-school traditional companies
so yeah Rohan is entirely correct and
saying good good recruiters that know
what's going on will realize that a free
code camp certificate is a good
indication of of what a good developer
can do Amelia said I've made mistakes of
putting that same price on the same
level with PHP apps yeah yeah definitely
and that takes time to realize like with
different types of things like how much
time it will take in different things so
you just got to get a feel for that the
level of customization that a client
wants will definitely make it so much it
can take something that's gonna be so
easy and make it so difficult that
that's happened to me so many times that
I haven't taken a time upfront to get an
idea of what a client expects and then
the project ends up taking longer and
I've had to go back to the client
sometimes and say like this is outside
the scope like we're gonna have to
renegotiate you know and sometimes
clients are okay with that sometimes
they get really upset about that so
definitely better to I kind of think
it's better to overestimate upfront how
long it's gonna take you it's much
easier and it's happier on a client if
you get to the end of the project and
you feel like wow I this this was so
easy and it didn't take me very long at
all I feel bad taking this much money
from a person if you need to to clear
your conscience you can always give
money back and the client will be really
really happy and they'll probably tell
everybody how awesome you are but if you
underestimate and that halfway through
the project you have to say listen I
can't do any more work on this unless
you pay me more the clients gonna be mad
you know that even even if they're a
really good client they're still not
gonna like the fact that now to them
it's over budget and you're less likely
to get referrals so it's after years of
going through it my advice would be
always always overestimate the amount of
time and money something's going to take
if the clients still okay with that
then that's probably great and they're
gonna be a good client for you and I
have had the situation before where I
overestimated a lot and I gave the
client money back or I simply said like
in the case of if they hadn't billed
them yet i billed him for way less than
i said i was gonna build him for because
and I just explained like this ended up
taking being way easier than I expected
you know here and and that built up a
lot of trust and I ended up get getting
paid way more later on for future
projects from that client because I was
willing to give you know I think I
charged them I think I said I was going
to charge them $200 and I only charged a
month $100 which is a 50% discount
that's big but at the end of the day
it's tolling a hundred bucks I ended up
making well over ten thousand dollars
total from that client over the course
of you know the time that I worked with
them so in the grand scheme of things
that hundred bucks wasn't a big deal but
it really helped build up trust with
that client that they were like willing
to trust me with even bigger projects
mayor dad asks where can I find the
first essence of live coding yeah the
very first sessions are on my youtube
channel so it's a the link to it is in
the description
I think it's Jesse or waggle is then the
channel name but I can't remember for
sure but anyway the first few videos for
this project are there so that was
before I started I started the project
before I started doing videos for free
code ken Jeremy says well I've been
working and had my volume down and you
guys are still going awesome cool
alright glad you're back Jeremy did you
start your new job yet if so how's it
going if not when are you gonna start
Rowan says being in traditional learning
environment currently so Rowan's right
now in a traditional environment and
having worked with people on real-world
projects the difference is astounding
and Santa says I agree rhoann working on
real-time projects is the best way to
learn yeah I mean I work at a college
and I still agree like you learn a lot
by actually doing things so that's that
is the best way I mean there's
definitely value in some degrees more
than those of others of course but
there's certain situations where you do
want a degree but if you want to be like
a front-end developer that's a job where
I would say you most likely don't need a
degree and if if you want the degree
then you know maybe you have a good
reason but I don't think it's necessary
hey my it's here hey how's it going and
aim high also has a new job so how is
your job going to
so I'm gonna wait I'm actually at the
end of the live chat now but I've asked
some questions of people so I'm gonna
wait maybe just a few more seconds to
see if I get any responses and then
after that I'm just gonna add so I'll
kind of give my ending some of my ending
remarks right now while I'm waiting on a
response but anyway yeah if you haven't
gotten a question in and you still want
to ask some questions you can put it in
the comments for this video or you can
direct message me on Twitter or just
regular message me on Twitter I'd be
happy to answer you know whenever I get
a chance and oh I actually got some more
stuff in the live chat now so Jeremy
said I did start it's going good got
some great workers and fun projects
awesome I'm really glad to hear that yes
so you'll have to keep us updated on the
projects never I won't but I won't bug
you about it every time but occasionally
I will ask you how things are going and
yeah that's um I don't know I just get
super excited every time I hear that one
of you have you know gotten a job and
stuff that's that's really cool it's
really cool to be able to get paid every
day to do something that you really love
that's kind of that's a great situation
Jeremy said boss asked me to do some
public speaking at high schools to get
young generations motivated that's
awesome that sounds really cool that's a
really great idea that's that's cool
that your bosses is interested in that
so yeah that's awesome hopefully you
have some success with that and get some
I know it can be hard to speak I used to
teach at high school so I know it can be
hard to speak to high school kids but
the good good luck with that
Daniel says I want a front-end job to
help me find for my degree I'm not
exactly sure what what you're saying
Daniel so maybe I'm just reading it
wrong or whatever but if you want to
rephrase it try to help me understand
please please do so Rowland so it's the
only good thing that happened to me with
uni is making new friends yeah that's
true you do get you make friends
Joseph said and don't forget the beer
yeah this that's true
College seems to be the place where a
lot of alcohol gets consumed all right
EMI who also got the new job says it's
been brilliant learn lots of good
commands first week branching pool
requests you name it my learning has
just begun and all AK is awesome
alright that's great that sounds cool
yeah I get get is super super super
helpful if any of you don't know how to
use git yet especially from the command
line I recommend you know learning that
it's just it's really useful and a lot
of jobs in the Job Description they like
candidates that know how to use git and
slack is definitely awesome I enjoy
using slack brian says hi Jesse I'm a
data scientist and wanted to know what
your thoughts on using both R and
JavaScript really want to go forward
with three code Campbell will it add
value I don't really have a lot of
experience with R so I don't think I can
give you a good answer I will say though
in terms of JavaScript it seems like
JavaScript is is being used in more and
more places so I don't think it's it's
ever kind of a waste to learn more about
JavaScript because it's so versatile you
know because I mean obviously anybody
with a web browser like you can write
stuff in JavaScript and they can use it
so I mean that just puts it everywhere
right away but there's also Internet
things devices that you can program in
JavaScript so and then with with things
like react native you know mobile apps
can be in JavaScript and VR can be in
JavaScript and so I don't think it would
be a waste to learn to do JavaScript
things although if there was something
really specific that you wanted to do
that didn't necessarily need JavaScript
then maybe you it would be more valuable
to spend your time learning other things
so it does somewhat depend on what you
want to do but there you know there are
just a lot of opportunities and jobs
that use JavaScript that I mean
generally speaking in most situations I
don't think it would be a waste to learn
JavaScript I think it would add value
but like I said I can't say for sure in
terms of data science and using our with
JavaScript because I don't really have
experience or very much knowledge of
that so sorry I couldn't give you a
better answer on that Brian Jordan says
his bootstrap good to use yeah I think
bootstrap is pretty good oz Anna say and
she's gonna go to sleep all right good
night Anna thanks for joining us thanks
for all your contributions in the live
stream are in the live chat I mean but
back to bootstrap yeah Jordan I think
bootstrap is a pretty among you know
framework CSS frameworks like that
bootstrap I think is one of the better
ones so I don't use bootstrap currently
for any projects I have used it before
though and I think it's a good it's a
good framework Jessica added that
foundation it's also another framework
that's good yeah I've Foundation seems
to be pretty good as well and I use
materialized it's not nearly as
well-known as foundation and bootstrap
but if you like material design
materializes I think it did a decent
option
let's see one ass says really nice dream
Jessie I'm in backend learning front end
greetings from Peru hey thanks for
joining us thanks for joining us from
Peru and that's cool so you're already
in back in and now you're learning front
end that's really cool I feel like I'm
going the opposite way that I'm I'm in
front end and I'm learning some back end
so welcome you'll definitely be able to
contribute in in the chat and help me
out with some backend stuff then
occasionally I do need to do some
backend things so I'm very much a
beginner in that area so I welcome any
any advice you have for me Roland says
don't drink so no beer for me but yeah
lots of beer was used in general yeah
that's probably a better way to go I
think you you probably learn a lot more
in school if you weren't drinking then
if you were I know some people who drank
a lot in school and never and never got
a degree but they drink a lot alcohol
this is quite expensive thing expensive
partying since they didn't end up with a
degree anyway but still paid for one
dancer daniel said I want a front end
job to fund for my degree I don't want a
student loan oh okay alright so Daniels
saying wants to get the front end job be
able to make money to pay for the degree
without getting a student loan actually
that's that's a pretty good idea
so yeah cuz you can definitely do front
end work you know freelance stuff remote
work and still be able to do you know do
school at the same time so yeah that's a
great idea I was very lucky that I
didn't I didn't have loans a lot of
loans that hadn't paid back or anything
but I have I have friends and family
that just have so much money in student
loans there and so much debt it's really
hard to get out of the debt from a
student loan and sometimes Roland says
freelance websites alright so this is in
terms of like how would how would you
make money freelancing is freelance
websites and ask your friends and family
just
read the word yeah definitely previous
websites can be tough to make a lot of
money off of it takes a while to build
up your reputation on them but then yeah
friends and family are really good if
you have them to be able to you know
just have you know they can just talk to
people I'm sure you know they probably
know people who need websites and things
and that's definitely a good way to get
started
aim high so it's been exposed to a lot
of react Redux code since I started and
immutable Jaz that's really cool
yeah I definitely I'm gonna be learning
more about Redux soon so maybe I'll have
some of that on the stream too maybe
it'll be helpful for you maybe you can
help me since you're already being
exposed to Jordan says I'm learning
front and back-end that's cool if you
can learn both and be full stack then
you can definitely make some good money
Roland says freelance is good starting
out in general to make a portfolio and
to get some experience so yeah alright
whoa it is been quite a long stream and
we had definitely a nice chat got a lot
of questions answered so hopefully
especially for some of you maybe we're
beginning and things hopefully get some
good information out of the chat the
coding portion of it was not what not
didn't go quite as well as I wanted to
but that happens sometimes but anyway
thank ya thanks everyone for watching
and I really appreciate all the
contributions that you all made in the
live chat I will be back tomorrow most
likely at the same time I don't think I
have anything that will interrupt that
and until then I won't have a great day